so
i got interested in in this topic of the
seven deadly sins
some years ago in part because i focus a
lot of my research on
one of them anger and
in the the categories of the seven
deadly sins you always find
discussions of anger wrath you know
there's a lot of different words
that are used for that and i got i got
interested in this in part because i
wanted to look at treatments
of anger across theology
and across philosophy so some of the
people who talk a lot about it located
within the context of the seven deadly
sins
and when i started researching this i
found this guy john
cassian who is one of the people that's
going to show up in the story that i'm
going to lead you through
yeah instead of talking about the seven
deadly sins which i you know heard about
since i was a kid
he talked about the eight capital vices
so i thought well that's a little bit
odd how did we go from eight down to
seven
and y is a capital vices instead of
deadly sins
and as i started looking into it i found
that there were a lot of different
transitions that
took place and
from being interested in cassian's
treatment of anger i started getting
interested in some of the treatments of
the other things that he was talking
about for example
he listed sadness
among tristitia in latin among the
capital vices well that's that's kind of
strange too i mean when we think of the
seven deadly sins we think of things
like envy and pride and
anger and greed and lust you know we
don't think of being sad
as is a problem if you think of that as
like
you know somebody's angry at me and
hurts me then i get to be sad
so why would calcium consider that to be
uh among these these precursors of the
the deadly sins
so as i looked into this it's one of
those sort of topics where the more that
you
pull out the threads the more it starts
to
unravel and other threads start coming
with it and i'm still nowhere
near where i'd like to be in my my
research on this
you keep on finding more and more
discussions of people arranging these
focusing on these but after a while some
things
do become clear from this almost
cacophony
of voices talking about sins and how to
classify them
certain themes and certain
preoccupations
show themselves to be you know you might
say structural they're
they're determining what's actually
going on
so before i actually talk about what
what is a
deadly center of capital vice i want to
talk a little bit about
four approaches that are taken to
these these sins or these vices and
the people that are interested in
talking about this and thinking about
this sort of stuff
they have very specific things in mind
there are reasons
why they are thinking about this writing
about this
preaching about it uh trying to live it
out
they have to do with what it is that
their their function is
are they a monk are they somebody who
has to hear confessions
are they a poet are they
a university professor those are the
four types of characters that show up in
the stories i'm going to tell them
there's all there's two artists
but i'm not going to talk about artists
because we don't have the time to
talk about all the different iconography
of this sort of thing
these people were interested in
identifying the key complexes and
producers of many sins if you think
about
this basic idea how many ways can a
human being go wrong
is it just seven is it 700
is it almost infinite aristotle said you
know it's almost infinite
that was back before christianity showed
up and said some things that you greeks
are saying are okay are not okay anymore
um probably right about that
by the way
if you can if you can figure out what
are the main causes for people being
screwed up
then you have a better shot at helping
them not to be screwed up
and helping them to make progress in
their lives
whether it's temporal or spiritual
um another thing that was going on is
these people were condensing
human experience these are all very
smart people who are
talking and writing about these these
bad traits and they're looking at what's
going on around them
they're not academics in the sort of
sense that you're used to
where people often think of it as a sort
of ivory tower detached from
you know day-to-day reality it's not
actually the case just following a
university professor around here a day
and find out that's not the case but
that's a conception we have
these were people who had to live in
monasteries with a bunch of other monks
who are
often times no fun and deal with
teaching children brought to the
monastery because that's the only place
to study
or with you know being called on by the
emperor to
come and be his counselor as alkaven had
to
or being stuck being pope against your
will
like gregory the first uh who just
wanted to be a benedictine monk and
leave all that sort of stuff behind
so these are these are people who are
trying to take what they
see going on and the wisdom of
generations
and think about this in the light of
christian doctrine
so
when we lose this kind of context then
the seven deadly sins become kind of
trivialized
if you go online you'll find and just
type in seven deadly sets
um you'll get a wikipedia article of
course right and it'll pop up at
the top and that's interesting but
you'll get a whole bunch of other things
like the seven deadly sins of media
communications and seven deadly sins of
selling cards and the seven deadly sins
of this and seven the
sins of that there's a lot of images
there's a seven deadly sins of websites
and you know you can actually see them i
forget what was what like uh there's
some food thing that's the gluttony one
what was the anger one i can't remember
offhand
some pornography site is the lost wand
of course
youtube is in there facebook is the one
for envy
uh you know a lot of this makes sense
but if we
if we get away from the actual context
it just turns into like well there's
these seven bad
characteristics and we'll see how we can
fit things in and it gets very
forced you'll also find a lot of artwork
where there's seven women you know and
the the one who's envy how do you know
she's dead because she's in green
and the one who's lost is purple and the
one who's
angry what do you think she is
yeah of course red right she's not going
to be yellow or something like that
there's a kind of standard iconography
but it gets kind of flattened out these
people were really
thinking about about this stuff so
there's four main contexts
the first context is these desert monks
out there
in egypt primarily also someone in
palestine
and they're trying to reflect on
how we get screwed up being
screwed up keeps us from being able to
love our neighbor
and to love god and put ourselves on the
right path
what are the ways in which we get
screwed up how does that take place how
can we keep that from happening
what they had to say gets taken on by a
lot of other people
then early on there's also a poetic
context
uh around the same time as these monks
are writing about this there's a latin
poet credenceus who
writes about sins not exactly the same
as the other ones
but he does some important things then
much later
after the fourth ladder of council
there's this incredible emphasis
on going to confession and that
everybody has to go to confession once a
year which means that
somebody's got to hear all those
confessions right
a lot of people see it as oh the poor
laity they have to go to confession
think about that poor priest who's stuck
hearing all these confessions because
these are people actually coming to him
and expecting some sort of guidance
they're revealing how they're screwed up
and this guy who probably you know
doesn't have that much training
has to give advice that will actually
help these people out
so there were people who wrote uh
books to try to help them do this better
there's a few interesting things that
you know a little excessive things that
happen with that that
we'll talk about and then there's this
scholastic context
as you you guys all know from your
history classes the universities develop
um in in some some major towns like
paris
and paris is where you would go to study
theology and you would study theology
there
primarily so you could go be a priest
somewhere else
and people like thomas aquinas who i
know you've all heard of but other
scholastics are also thinking about the
sins so what is it what is a deadly sin
what makes a
why should we call some sins deadly
isn't that kind of overkill
what do you think i mean it's not like
if you
feel pride you're automatically going to
hell
or you're gonna die like you know we do
that in movies like number seven
have you guys all seen seven this guy's
punishing these people
and at the very end brad pitt has to
become wrath
you know cap it all off well it's not
quite like that it's not quite so
straightforward
as well i'm lazy so somebody's gonna tie
me to a bed
yeah that's a good way to put it each of
them has a tendency
to seduce us to lead us into thinking
that's not that big of a deal now that
it gets bigger and bigger and bigger
and they also are things that lead to
other
mistakes they're productive
of other ways of getting things wrong so
if i have a terrible temper
what are some of the things i'm liable
to do that aren't
directly anger but come from me
yeah yeah i'll engage in violence
against other people
take revenge imagined insults slander
people
feel rancor within myself be be a jerk
in general and
and make everybody uncomfortable you
know
i mean we could go down a whole list
right everybody knows what it's like to
be angry
and what what excessive anger looks like
so
each of these can be understood not only
in terms of ways in which we go wrong
but also in terms of another concept
which gets brought in virtue um
you guys all you know probably run into
this in your intro to philosophy class
or in an ethics class you heard
something about what virtue is
virtues are good character traits and
for you know within the christian
framework they absorbed
the concept of virtues like justice
courage
prudence temperance that the ancients
before them
were talking about and then they talked
about theological virtues like faith and
hope and charity
as being states that you wanted to to
cultivate within yourself it's not
enough just to like do the right thing
you want to actually have the right sort
of
frame of mind you want to have the right
habits you want to be the right kind of
person and these sins are things which
go away at or block or interfere with
our development of the virtues um
so let's let's move on and let's talk
about
the eight deadly sets the eight capital
devices
at the start there there's eight and
they're not actually
vices they're actually thoughts the
first guy who talks about this
is a monk named ivagris ponticus
and he's a guy who starts out
in palestine and wants a more rigorous
you know monastic experience so it goes
out in the desert
monaco originally means solitary
comes from greek and the first monks
would go out in the desert and why would
they do that
they just couldn't stand people that
wasn't that
they wanted to remove distractions so
they could they could pray
so they could contemplate so they could
cultivate a life with god
and how well do you think that went
let's just take a guess you have an
intention of like
i'm going to get away from it all and
i'll just hang out
and you know say my psalter and
pray and god will be with me
and i'll have food and water and stuff
like that i have to worry about that and
clothing
it didn't actually go that well in a lot
of cases
in part because you bring to the desert
yourself
and if you're screwed up if you have
flaws within you
like like john cassian will say later
you know you can you can take your anger
out in the desert
and instead of getting angry at that
people you're going to get angry at
rocks you're going to get angry at other
things
because you've brought the anger with
you if you have greed
if you have lust if you have gluttony
you're going to bring those things with
you
and ponticus and this is on um
one of the handouts that i i created for
you
he talks about the eight thoughts logies
in greek these thoughts are things that
um
get suggested to us and we're
particularly suggestible creatures
and in his view it's demons the fallen
angels that are suggesting these
thoughts to us
and if we resist them we're okay
if we give in to them they wound our
soul and they take a root in
inside of us and they steer us into
doing bad things
uh not like they take over it you know
and make us uh
a zest or you know like like they turn
us into a mechanism
they they have us actually doing the
wrong thing by our own choice
and so he talks about eight of these
and many of these you'll recognize from
a list of the seven deadly sins
there's gluttony there's lust or sexual
immorality
literally in greek just wickedness
pulmonary house
sadness blue face
anger and then one that's not translated
that we call acadia
i'll tell you a little bit about that in
a moment vainglory canodoxia literally
like
empty making too much of oneself and
then finally pride
and any of these can attack us during
our lives
and if we don't resist them then they
will
start steering us to go in different
directions we're susceptible to that
they actually tap into different parts
of our our soul
so the lower parts are subject to lost
or gluttony
the the part of us that's actually
dynamic that seeks out honor
part of us in which courage can be
located can also become angry
and also become dejected and despairing
even the mind itself is subject to
pride and vainglory to thinking too much
of oneself for the wrong reasons
and what he tells us about about these
is is anger he says is the sharpest of
the passions
the one that actually infects the very
uh faculty by which we should resist
evil
we're given this this ability to fight
in order to resist evil but what anger
does
is it helps it doesn't help it seduces
us
into actually using that to fight
against our neighbors or fight against
ourselves
or fight against god and
acadia is called the noonday w this this
comes from a psalm
where they talk about you know the devil
who stalks around at noonday
and the monks very early on recognized
that there's a kind of restlessness a
kind of inability to stick to things and
get things done
you all know that from from being
students right
when you have an assignment to do or
something to read and you like you know
you read over it a bit
i do this too and you get to the end of
the passage and you realize you haven't
paid any attention to what you're
reading
that can be acadia when you can't stay
in your in your room
and focus on your tasks and you start
going around looking what everyone else
is doing
not because you're envious of them but
because you just you know want to know
what they're doing
maybe to help even help them out that
can be acadia
that distracts you from from your tests
it keeps you from being able to
persevere he says this is actually the
most heavy of the demons for thoughts
and then vainglory and pride are
particularly problematic
why do you think that is
if i'm at lawton if i want to eat too
much or drink too much or indulge myself
and
sensual appetite too much
that's pretty easy to tell right
i mean you just watch for a while you
get fat
right unless you're getting some sort of
screwed up metabolism or a tapeworm
or something like that um
that's pretty easy to watch too you know
and you know that these things are bad
pride and vainglory come in and they
they use the things that are good about
you
to make too much of yourself so let's
say you conquer your anger
that's a tough thing to do any of you
who struggle with anger problems
you conquer your anger now you can
become prideful about that
now you can think that you should
probably write books about anger
you should go on a tour you should go to
if you're a monk
you should go around all the other monks
and help them straighten out their anger
problem
and when you do that they're going to
say what a swell
person you are and you can start
imagining
how this is going to work and you start
you're getting higher and higher and
higher that's vainglory that's what he's
talking about there
um so these are all things we can relate
to i think
right these these monks their experience
is not that far off from us
so that's a vagaries ponticus john
cassian comes a little bit later and he
writes a lot more about this stuff and
instead of talking about in terms of
thoughts
he talks about in terms of vices
character traits that become established
in us because we
act in certain ways when we give in to
the desire to eat and eat and eat that
becomes stronger
as a desire right it doesn't go away
when you satisfy it when we give in to
the desire to take revenge
for being slighted through anger
we uh we often say i just have to you
know let my anger
be dispensed on something we're actually
making ourselves worse
it becomes harder the next time to
resist it and so
uh cassian talks about this in in two
very important documents
the institutes
and then these um conferences
the conferences are coming from cassio
and actually going out the desert
himself
he started out in the west he travels
east with his friend
he wants to become a monk and you know
sort of like if you want to go to the
best schools and go to the best
monasteries to learn how to be a monk
he goes to the ones in palestine and
like a vegas pontius decides this isn't
rigorous enough for me they go down to
egypt
and he spends time going around and you
know
staying at these monasteries and talking
to the abbots
the guys who are in charge and saying
well how do you guys actually do this
what's working for you what's not
working for you so like quality testing
in business terms and out of this comes
a whole
set of books and and he talks about
these those
devices as well and i'm not going to say
too much about that
what i do want to say is that
cassian gets rec he goes back to the to
the west and he writes these books
and he gets recommended as reading
required reading by saint benedict
who organizes the benedictine order this
is a very fateful move
because that means that all these
benedictine monks if they're
actually paying attention and many of
them were not we know this from actually
reading what benedict and monks wrote
about other benedict and monks
they're coming into contact with this
notion there are these eight
capital vices here's what they are
here's what they look like
here's how you fight against them here's
how they're connected to each other
here's how you know for example gluttony
gives rise to lust because when you when
you're full
and you've had enough to eat um then
it's a lot easier to start thinking
about having sex
all the time you know um and and you
know pride can give rise to envy can
give rise to anger can give rise to
rejection
all these sorts of things this is very
useful information for them to have
so one of the very important people in
the benedict
order now we're moving ahead in time
quite a bit
to
gregory the first so we're now in the
sixth century
gregory the first becomes a pope against
his wishes he's one of those kind of
guys who is living at a terrible time
when it's hard to get good health and he
is good health
and he's great at organizing things he's
really smart
and what do you really like to do is
just be you know in his monastery and
pray and be left alone
but they make him pope and uh
back then it wasn't you know there
weren't a lot of perks for being both uh
really it's kind of a bad job to get
stuck with for for almost anybody
um i know i certainly couldn't could do
anything remotely like that
gregory writes a book called moralia in
job which means an interpretation of the
book of job
the wisdom literature in a moral sense
and in it he has a passage where he
talks about the seven deadly sins
now you notice we went from eight to
seven right
he actually does talk about the eight
capital places but he he changes things
around a bit
he says pride is the root
the ruling vice of all of these others
pride is like
he's actually commenting on some
scripture verses he smelleth the battle
far off
which is in the book of job and the
exhortation of the captains and the
howling of the army so there's a lot of
military
metaphors going on there pride is like
the general
and what do generals have
soldiers down at the bottom right but is
that all there is
over the soldiers and under the gem
you don't just have that one guy saying
dude do this do that because he can't
possibly
pay attention to everybody you have
captains or you know
majors pick whatever rank you are right
they use the term captains of this
pride is the sin the
vice that flows into these seven other
vices
which then flow into many others
pride is he says the queen of sins and
when it occupies the heart it surrenders
it to these seven principle vices or
sins
each of these brings its own forces
and these lead to each other gregory
also mentions that
we have to be very careful not to allow
our virtues the good things about us
to be turned into pride because if we do
we're lost and he's writing this
not just to monks but also lay people
because he's
he's a [ __ ]
we have to be careful not to allow good
traits about ourselves like
justice to turn into cruelty or
zeal into anger or
gentleness into sloth so he's telling us
some very interesting things about this
what's most important for the story that
i'm telling you here
is now there's seven cents
and if you look at the sins that he
talks about
he didn't just say well pride we're
going to put over here
and then we'll look at these seven he
also changed
some of the sins around
he keeps gluttony and
keeps lost and keeps greed those will
stay in the entire time
but what he what does he actually take
out
he rolls sadness
and acadia into one single vice
sadness tristitia allowing oneself to
feel despair
to be distracted to not to not actually
focus on the things that one needs to
focus on
and he brings in a new one envy
before that some of these guys would
talk about envy but envy wasn't one of
the
major vices it takes a while for this to
stick we can see that
you know for instance alkuan who's
writing several centuries after gregory
goes back to the eighth capital vices
other
other monks like for example
hugo st victor use gregory's things
there's a guy isadora seville a very
literate guy
in in spain and spain is starting to go
into
to the dark ages who writes
a number of books one of which is called
the centennial or the
on the greatest on the highest good
and he actually talks about the seven
deadly sins the way that gregory does
he also does something that's very
important he starts talking about
virtue's opposing sins
so for each sin each vice
there is a virtue that combats it
later on of saint victor he's going to
write a book called five
sevens literally and seven
five one of those sevens is the seven
deadly sins
now they're starting to think about what
can we do to actually resist these what
are some of the other things
seven virtues to oppose them seven
passages from scripture they are father
seven parts of that but you know attack
the the different sins
seven gifts of the holy spirit they
start really getting into those number
seven
other words and seeing a lot of
parallels they're helped out
and now i have to backtrack a little bit
by this poet prudences
and prudencius writes a book called the
psychomachia and that means the fight
for the soul
and if you ever have a chance to read it
read it because it's very gory
and a lot of funny things happen in it
and the vices and they're not exactly
the same thing
or the sins they're not exactly the same
list that gregory is using
they fight against the virtues and so
you know first it's um
uh faith versus worship of the old gods
and then it's chastity versus lust and
you know they tussle for a while
and then you know chastity actually
kills lust
and then uh patience goes into the list
against wrath
and wrath brings every weapon possible
these are all these are all women too by
the way fighting
and wrath is like slicing at patients
and trying to destroy her and getting
you angrier and angrier and angrier
and finally all of her weapons break and
she dies she dies by her own hand
um and then there's you know other
little things that happen pride comes
along
and is riding on this great horse and
saying to all of them there's no way you
can resist me unless she falls into a
pit that was actually dug by one of the
other vices
greed comes along and pretends to be
thrift and almost takes them unaware
and then finally the very last battle
discord attacks
and starts turning them against each
other and then finally
concord or harmony turns up and sticks
her in the heart
and it's all over now why why is all
this kind of
what's up may sound you know my
rendition a little silly why is this
important
because you have personification of the
different
vices and the different virtues fighting
against each other it is literally a
batter
battle for the soul the human soul
this is going to influence artistic
representations
and uh what the monks are thinking
and all these these other people um
now i'm going to speed the story up a
little bit because i don't want to
keep you over time and i do want to have
time for questions
i'm actually going to skip over talking
about who doesn't think in terms of 37.
there's a lot of important medieval
authors who don't actually
address that anselm is is one that i
particularly like
he talks in terms of pride being a river
that flows into three
other rivers and he's he's getting this
from augustine's
emphasis on um the three types of
desire you know that can lead us astray
the lust of the flesh the lust of the
eyes and the pride of life
so what what anselm is saying fits into
that not everybody bought into that
but um
one of the things that happens that that
really affects the story that that
brings the seven deadly sins
into into real prominence
probably the reason why we talk about
them today still
is in the fourth labyrinth council it's
decided that everybody has to go to
confessions here
which like i said before that means some
poor priest has to hear all these
people's confessions once a year
everybody above a certain age and these
priests
need some sort of guidance on how to
figure out
what's wrong with these people and
what's wrong with their behavior and
what you know what are the root causes
of this so they can give them some
useful advice
and they also need to figure out how
serious are the sins that these people
are engaged in
because you know once people start going
to confession they start to actually
worry about this kind of thing you know
maybe the first time they go they're
like ah
i did this and i did that this is just
pro forma
but then they start thinking about it
yeah actually i am kind of a bad guy
uh i better get my act together i don't
want to go to hell
maybe i don't even want to screw up my
life here and so they they need to know
how serious these things are so you have
these uh people
and by this time new orders have arisen
it's not a benedictine thing
it's largely a dominican and franciscan
thing
a lot of the dominicans start writing
these these manuals for confessors
sort of like a guidebook how to hear
somebody's confession
and they can get pretty detailed and
they use the seven deadly sins
as a kind of rubric sort of like you
might use them to organize
powerpoint when you're putting together
a presentation
it provides them with a very they're not
getting engaging in a lot of analysis
of you know psychology or anything like
that what's really going on with the
human being that's going to happen with
the scholastic authors
these people are interested in a very
practical purpose and so you get these
guys like you know
raymond penafort and william payroll
and john of freiburg all writing these
these these
books that are going to become
influential not only on priests but even
on poets
later on jeffrey chaucer
incorporates some of this you guys know
from the canterbury tales
at the same time the universities are
arising
before that schooling is largely taking
place in the monasteries
and at the cathedrals when the
universities arise you have a new way of
approaching things
there's a lot of things coming together
at the same time
one of these things is the rediscovery
of aerosols texts
they only had a few of them in the early
middle ages
and then once they get aristotle's
system which some of you may have
encountered in your ethics classes
if you've taken that so so far your
intro to philosophy class
aerosol had a very detailed work through
classification of the virtues and vices
that didn't map onto this stuff
and they're trying to make sense of that
they're trying to figure out how
can we actually classify these things
so you know for example peter lombard
who's one of the early guys he writes
this book called the sentences and then
just about everybody who is everybody
had to write a commentary on the
sentences like in your capping classes
you know you're going to write on
somebody in your in your field that
would be your capping class
and lombard said there's four ways to
class by sins
augustine said you could classify them
in terms of covetousness or fear and
what kind
they're coming out of jerome who is
another great doctor of the church said
you can think about it in terms of
thought or word indeed
that's a fundamental classification or
you can think about who they're against
what makes something a sin it's against
somebody so it could be against god
or it could be against yourself or it
could be against your neighbor
or then he says you can also do the
senate that he says
the list that gregory gave us which he
got
from cassian and modified from casket so
this list
is coming through all the way back from
these monks
into the doctors the school masters
and their uh you know
bonaventure appropriates this all these
others william oxaire
um one of the people who's the most
important in how he approaches this is
thomas aquinas
probably the one of the most brilliant
of the
scholastic doctors and he spends a lot
of time
exploring these sins from gregory's list
and he discusses a lot of ways of
dividing the sins
um he actually gets into discussions
about which is the you know the real
root of sin
is it greed or is it pride read it is in
a certain way sort of like a
a tree is you know it's a trunk and
everything is nourished by the sap
flowing through it
but then again pride is the beginning of
all of these sins
and then he you know looks at
how all these sins are are contrary to
certain virtues
so you know he'll discuss vain glory
and how it's opposed to genuine courage
in a person
or he'll talk about sloth and he decides
the problem with sloth too he says that
that
chaosian was distinguishing sadness from
acadia but but
gregory actually got it right by
slurring these things in together so
thomas kind of gives you a decisive
voice on that
but sloth as opposed to genuine love for
other people
and love for god um anger
you know what would anger be opposed to
the monks would have said patience
thomas aquinas says temperance control
of one's appetites
is really what's what's missing
in the person who's driven by anger um
and he talks also about the daughters of
the sense
meaning that each one of these things
gives rise
gregory talked about like each one of
them having an army aquinas talks in
terms of them having
daughters so for example um
envy what does henry bring about hatred
tail there you know saying bad things
about people behind their back
detraction
joy at our neighbor's misfortunes grief
for our neighbors prosperity these are
all bad things they have and they all
come from envy so if you can attack
envy at its roots you can knock out some
of this other
behavior the last
group of people i want to talk about are
the poets
and you notice i sort of i talked about
pretend prudencias and then i didn't
talk about anyone else it's not really
until
later on that the poets start thinking
in terms of the seven deadly sins
some people want to try to read it into
payable but there's really not a good
argument for that
um you know you can see some of the
characters is representing certain
things but the author doesn't say
anything like that and there's no real
discussion of it
um but dante how many of you read dante
in any of your classes you read the
infernal problem right
have any of you read the purgatory yeah
that one actually is more closely
connected to the
797s they do show up in the inferno
because when you start going down
right after you get past limbo where the
poor staffs who didn't have the chance
to actually hear the gospel are
stuck even if you know they're not too
bad
um any of the you know the people who
you know are totally indecisive and
chasing the ever shifting banner all
around as well
we start going into the circles of hell
and the circles of hell
start out being organized with the seven
deadly sins lusts
then gluttony then greed then wrath
but then they depart from that because
then it's heresy and violence and fraud
and treachery but when we look at the
purgatory
which has an ascending
sort of sort of structure to it you know
you're climbing the mountain
the things that are being purged away at
each point are the seven deadly sins
it's become consolidated by this point
and you know when somebody like dante
endorses it
that really solidifies them there were
other people jeffrey chaucer how many of
you have read
the cut the canterbury tales anyone read
that in high school or hear it
if you haven't read it you should read
it quite quick one of the tales the
parsons tale has a discussion of this
um william langlin in piers plaumon one
of the very
early quite famous middle english
poetry he has a parade of the seven
deadly sins
john gower has this confession of montes
where
he actually organizes a whole bunch of
stories he took from everybody else he
didn't actually make up anything himself
but he organizes them according to the
seven deadly sins so for example
um avarice he tells the story of midas
remember who king midas was anybody
not that not the ear thing you know he
got head asses ears for a while
do you remember anything about the minus
touch yeah
yeah and he asked for that because he
was so greedy and then
of course he couldn't eat because he
touched you know food and turkey adults
he was unhappy
so there's a story about greed and then
he tells you a whole bunch of other
stories
and what does he put under there
jealousy for example jealousy is a kind
of greed of love
i want your love so much that nobody
else can have it
and he goes through all these things
there's also a really interesting poem
it's very short called the wounds and
the sins and it talks about the wounds
of
christ and each one of them is a way of
overcoming the seven deadly sins so
pride corresponds to the crown
of thorns andy corresponds to the spear
that's thrust into his side
gluttony corresponds to the gall the
crappy wine
and bitter stuff that they put on the
sponge for him
luxury or lost corresponds to his death
raoth corresponds to the right hand nail
greed
to the left hand nail and the nails
through the feet correspond to sloth
so you see these poets using these
schemes to make sense out of
other things to use do athletic
compositions so now we've got
all these different players involved
why are we talking about the seven
deadly sins all the time now
well in part because the protestant
reformation
you find catholics continuing to talk
about these things and you do find some
protestants picking it back up later on
but it came to be seen as a
distinctively catholic thing
by the way the seven deadly sins are not
like you know a binding way of looking
at everything
if you look at the catechism of the
catholic church you're not going to find
that
you know it's the only way to possibly
understand sin and everything is
organized that way
the catechism actually says you look at
it this way you look at it this way
very much like peter lombard
they become popularized but in the
popularization they've kind of lost a
lot of their
real meaning the real meaning resides in
these these
compositions by the poets if you want to
know about
about pride or greed or something like
that read dante
or read these scholastic authors like
thomas aquinas or if you're if you want
kind of a boring read read these these
confessors and their manuals because
it's very schematic
or if you want to see what you know
monastic life was like and what these
guys are struggling against read john
casket he's a fundraiser
i'll tell you something that's kind of
funny the addition that i have actually
the section on lust
the translation keeps that part in latin
because they don't want any any
school boys reading it and getting any
you know bright ideas about what you
might do this is actually a big problem
with the confessors too you can see this
in the manuals of confession
you you want to ask about what the
person's doing but you don't want to be
very specific you want to let them
volunteer the information
because you don't want to actually put
any ideas in their head about what they
might be doing and
missing out on that so
all this is is really interesting
reading it's all trying to figure out
these things that make human beings tick
it's it's very much you know within the
pattern of
not only theology but philosophy and
psychology
trying to figure out why are we screwed
up
how do we get less screwed up how can we
identify these
these patterns um the last
thing that i'll tell you about is this
guy saint john of the cross he was a
is after the the reformation
he's what they call a counter
reformation or a catholic reformation
figure he's a carmelite he's not a
dominican or a
franciscan or benedictine and he
actually talks in terms of
spiritual sense and during the spiritual
life a person
will be posed with the problem of
committing spiritual gluttony or
spiritual pride
or spiritual adverse
spiritual pride is when you go around
talking about you know what a spiritual
person you are
and how you know accomplished you are in
spirituality
and you actually believe this sort of
thing and it keeps you from actually
progressing
so it's a long story with a lot of
different threats
there's a lot of research still yet to
be done here
and i don't know if i've given you a uh
an organized enough tail for for this to
fully make sense to you but at the very
least now we know
why they were originally eight and how
there came to be seven and why
people came to feel that seven is the
number that we want to stick with
there's a lot of other things we could
have gone off on
and explored but i wanted to leave a
little bit of time for any questions
or comments interjections that you might
have
about this sort of stuff
yeah when you mentioned that
levels in purgatory were referenced by
the seven students
uh did they also have a correspondence
of the
crosses that were put on not this head
when he entered purgatory
and as he ascended up each level one of
the crosses would disappear
is there any association between that
and well i mean that's something that's
happening
that's a good question i mean is it like
there's a
is like a sin being purged off each time
yeah
it doesn't i mean it doesn't say like
and then the cross of literary
left or the cross of greed left or
something like that but yeah
that's that's that's a way to interpret
it i'm not a i'm not a dante scholar
myself i have to
just go by what they tell me i haven't
read a long time so i might
it's good it's a good question you know
and you could ask why does dante
actually
have he's not actually being purged the
way that the people in there are being
hurt he's being shown this stuff but
he is being purified by their example
and if you read it you know it's crazy
stuff they're going through
the people who are you know being purged
in anger i always pay attention anger
because that's my
like biggest problem to struggle with um
they gotta walk around
and fumes and they can't see anything
and just imagine like
you know the worst campfire ever that
you've been at where smoke is in your
eyes constantly
for like 100 years or a thousand years
you know
being around the people who are who are
gluttonous
they can't actually eat anything they're
stuck there they
like tantalus they reach out for fruit
and it like zips away and they're like
i should have known i'm not going to get
to eat anything the people who are
slothful
they got to work all the time they're
running around you know
but dante doesn't
what else what else are you curious
about or
irritated about it nice question yeah so
yeah i'm curious about
curiosity very curious oh foreign
right like nobody else seems like nobody
else really picks that
up yeah um that's a more augustinian way
of looking at it
and you know it's true like we think of
that now as a
a good thing yeah right right as a
virtue
yeah when these guys are talking about
curiosity they're not saying that you
shouldn't
be interested in thinking about it but
there's there's being curious about
stuff that doesn't really concern us at
all
there's none of our business and doesn't
help us out to find out about
and there's been a lot of discussions
lately about whether
social media contributes to this
you know by also to acadia by the way
whether social media makes us
more curious about other people's lives
in kind of non-edifying ways
than we ought to be you know
there's enough good things to be curious
about
that we don't have to there's here's the
understanding we don't have to spend our
time with these other things
but this curiosity thing is coming um
there's a three-part distinction pride
is the
beginning of these and then you have
delectatio sort of illicit pleasures and
things
you have curious curiosity and then you
have
exceltation sort of raising oneself
above
other people anselm used that as his way
of describing these
he he knew about the seven deadly sins
but he just didn't seem to
think they mattered and there were other
people like saint bernard saint bernard
talks about
um pride and vainglory and envy and then
that's it
he doesn't he doesn't buy the rest of
the the ordering of the sins he's got
enough other ways to think about sins
there's quite a few people abelard
doesn't doesn't use it um
augustine and jerome of course don't use
it but they probably didn't know about
cassie and stuff
ambrose doesn't use it
it really i think that the reason why
it took hold so strongly
ought to be attributed to these
confessors in their manuals
because even thomas aquinas his
treatment of it is kind of
stand-offish you know
you could look at the sins this way or
you can look at them this way you can
look at them this way
there's no internal necessity for them
the way there is for these
these compressors
so it seems like seems like uh curiosity
or curiosity is like
at least enhanced or at least related to
distraction because kind of presupposes
that there's too much food
to know anyway
i tried to fit ants on the in here i
don't know if it's really successful
i don't know so so acadia
um is this this uh
this allowing oneself to be distracted
al alcuin has this great metaphor
uh and this is his real contribution to
the discussion of it
uh it actually like physically throwing
the monk out of his
his room and making him go around and
like what's that guy doing over there
anything but focus on himself and his
own spiritual progress and what he's
supposed to be doing
you know how it is when you've got an
assignment and you
really don't feel like doing that
assignment you know you really need to
you'll find anything whatsoever else to
do you like clean up your room
you'll organize your notebooks you'll
you know
go into your pictures and like you know
maybe i should make an album
call other people maybe do a little
research
but it's not actually research that's
going to help you out on the assignments
you know that's acadia
that that's exactly what what they're
describing there
so the curio curiosity and handsome
sense i thought could kind of fit that
any other questions or
concerns
perhaps one last thing it seems like
just to go from the beginning to the end
that what happens to moving down to
seven is that sort of
pride sort of takes over vainglory
yeah so that's kind of absorbs it yeah
yeah it varies some some people are
saying pride is the root of all of these
like thomas and mice
pride is the or not the root pride is
the beginning of all these
greed is actually the root of all of
them and they all come in here
different people organize them different
ways like which one is more serious than
the other usually pride is at the top
and blocking your luster
at the bottom because they're carnal
rather than spiritual sins
there's a body rather than the soul um
but you know they vary in which ones
which one's worse gluttony or loss some
people are
thinking lust is worse some people are
thinking gluttony is i can tell you this
the monks thought that unless you
actually
tackle glutton you can't you can't do
any of the rest of them
you have to engage in fasting
a bare minimum to tackle any of the sets
of logs
if you look at thomas doesn't look like
he thought so
a big old guy you know he might have
land problems
but i don't think he missed a lot of
views so why
also why are they deadly oh because they
they um they tend to produce the kinds
of
things that will will be mortal sins
will lead to spiritual death
well sooner or later i mean if you have
a real solid anger problem it's not
going to take long before somebody sets
you off you know
same thing if you're envious you know
and you know if you think about these
they they're all they're all ways of
being
subject to something else even pride
with pride you think it's like i'm i'm
greater than everything else you're
stuck with your own self-image
your own ego and you can't get away from
it
that's you know a terrible way
angers horrible things to carry on
through all the time
sadness it's interesting that these
monks thought that dejection
being despairing was actually something
that could lead you to screw things up
well i thank you for uh your time and
your attention
and yeah